every Oscar show is special no more than
tonight as each of you here may be
comparing where you are sitting relative
to celebrity seat filler Carl sway bow
Carl give us a way Blair are there you
are my man Carl Carl has been seat
filling at the Oscars for 59 years now
starting back
his first night new chief rental tux was
when the greatest show on earth won best
picture at the Pantages Karl is
currently filling the seat of the
beautiful Jennifer Lopez who is
backstage right now prepping for her
time as a presenter but she'll be back
in her seat soon and Karl well he'll be
moving around the house it's big night
view Karl congratulations he's not
really a seat-filler he's just a guy but
nonetheless now let's give away a couple
of catta me Awards the filmmaker makes
the film but these first two categories
make the film's look the way they do
first here are the nominees for
achievement in cinematography the artist
the own Schiffman The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo Jeff Cronin Webb
Hugo Robert Richardson the Tree of Life
Emmanuel Lubezki warhorse
Janusz Kaminski and the Oscar goes to
Hugo Robert Richardson
[Applause]
this is the third Academy Award and
seventh nomination for Robert Richardson
he took home his first two Oscars in
this case
with JFK and the aviator
[Music]
I can't believe somebody put
cinematography up first that can only go
up from this point I want to thank you
all
Marty your genius as usual and Graham
sticking in there all the way I'd like
to thank en Chris Gregor conch and Maya
Beauty you're all my family and to all
the past future and present filmmakers
this is for you
[Applause]